-You know, this is --
this is your 14th appearance
on our show,
and I'm so grateful.
-It is?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Isn't that wild?
-Wow.
-I --
-Thank you.
I have to thank you
because when
you're first getting started,
it's not easy
to book these shows,
and you've been in my corner
since the very beginning,
so I thank you.
-We've been through a lot.
-We have been
through a lot together.
[ Laughs ]
-Last time I saw you,
we did an episode of
"That's My Jam" in L.A.
-Yes.
-And you were fantastic.
-Thank you.
-Blew the audience away.
-You always give me
great songs, though.
-Yeah. Well,
we got to make it good.
I'm sorry about the water.
-[ Sighs ]
-Well, you know,
here's the thing.
You knew that was
going to happen, right?
-I'm never prepared for it.
[ Laughter ]
You can't wet Black women's
hair like that.
I told you that, Jimmy.
We turn into Chia Pets right
in front of your very eyes.
You have to give us a heads-up.
-You were so -- like, 'cause
we give you protective glasses.
Like...
-I need a shower cap.
[ Laughter ]
An umbrella.
-Next time --
Next time we can do that.
-Yes.
-You know, I follow you
on the on the socials,
and I saw this amazing
photo of you here.
Explain what was happening here.
[ Audience cheering ]
-I mean --
-Yeah, exactly.
-You may have heard of Beyoncé.
I don't know.
-Yeah, absolutely.
-Well, the thing about it is,
I had already had
my outfit picked out
for her show months in advance,
and then she does this,
"Oh, it's my birthday.
Let's all wear silver."
[ Laughter ]
So, I mean, my house
is being renovated,
all of my clothes
are in storage,
and I randomly happened
to just buy this
off of those
Instagram shopping pages.
[ Laughter ]
And when it came,
I was about to throw it away
because it was like paper thin.
You could see through it.
But at the end of the day,
that's all I had for Beyoncé.
It was kind of silver,
had silver sparklies on it.
Long story short, I had to throw
it away at the end of the night
because it had snags
and holes and...
[ Laughter ]
But thanks, Instagram Shopping!
-I mean,
who else can pull this off?
-I pulled it off.
-I can't even imagine
seeing the concert with you
because I think that
you would end up on stage.
[ Laughter ]
And I'll tell you why.
-Why?
-Because I have a photo of you
on stage with Usher.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering ]
How do you end up --
Of course this is you.
How do you end up
on stage with Usher?
-Okay, well, it was
my birthday, and my girls
and I decided
to celebrate in Vegas.
And we were going
to the Usher concert,
and I kind of knew
something was going to happen
because they were like,
"Sit in this seat!"
I know what
the camera seats are.
So I sat in the seat.
I was so excited.
And he came to the stage, and he
wasn't ready to call me up yet.
And he looked over my way
and he was like,
"I see you, Taraji,"
and I thought that was my cue,
so I ran up on the stage
before --
[ Laughter ]
-He's like --
-And he didn't say anything.
-"I see --
Oh, she's coming up!"
-Usher is a female magnet.
I don't know if you know this,
but you're like drawn to him.
So cut to
I'm in Paris, Fashion Week,
and he's performing there.
And he's in the audience
doing his thing again,
and he sees Pharrell.
And you know I know Pharrell.
And so he says, "Hey,"
he gives Pharrell his flowers.
Then he looks across,
and he goes,
"Is that Taraji P. Henson?"
And I swear to God,
I took off running.
And there's something about him.
He's a magnet.
But you come in twerking.
[ Laughter ]
Promise you!
Look at all the footage.
It's not just me!
[ Laughter ]
-The way you walk up to Usher,
you just --
-You just come in twerking.
-You just end up twerking.
-That's how it happens.
He's a magnet,
and he pulls it out of you.
I don't twerk.
-Oh, my God.
-In public.
-Yeah, in public.
[ Laughter ]
I want to talk to you
about a couple things,
because during the pandemic,
you were nice enough
to me and the show.
You Zoomed in when we couldn't
leave the house or get guests.
And you were showing me this.
You're like, "I'm starting this
new line out of my kitchen."
-Oh, yes.
-Let's talk about this.
This is TPH.
-Yes.
-Okay.
Taraji P. Henson,
beauty products, hair...
-Hair and skin.
-And skin.
-Yeah.
-And by the way,
it's taken off now.
"Allure" magazine, you got
the Best of Beauty award.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was three years ago?
-Yeah.
-That's a lot of hard work
-We launched
during the pandemic.
But I think, you know,
my brand, I --
Guys, I also launched
a mental-health foundation
named after my father,
Boris Lawrence Henson
Foundation,
because in the Black
and Brown community,
we really don't talk about it,
and we're dying.
And so it's to eradicate
the stigma
around mental wellness
in the community.
But also during the pandemic,
everybody was going through it.
We were all feeling
some kind of way depressed
and not feeling
like ourselves,
and people were afraid
to be out amongst each other.
And so I wanted
to create a spa-like feeling
with products
that you can afford.
-There's a lot of work.
That's three years and now --
-We're everywhere --
Walmart, CVS, Target.
-I'm so happy for you.
-Yeah. Sally.
-It couldn't happen
to a better person.
-Thank you.
-And it's a good cause
behind it, too.
Let's talk about "Jaja."
-Oh, guys...
-This is a big deal.
Just opened tonight.
I'm honored that you're here
with us tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-My first time on Broadway
as a producer.
-"Jaja's African Hair Braiding."
-It's amazing.
-Can you explain
what it's about?
-So, for me,
what I love about this
is that I grew up
in Washington, D.C.
We didn't have a lot of African
braiding salons, right?
So I was always over at Pookie
or Peaches or somebody's cousin
sitting in between their legs
getting my hair braided.
So this was
an eye-opener for me.
But what struck me
as most interesting
is these women who are literally
like hidden figures,
and they work
in these braiding salons
in fear of being
deported every day.
And I never --
When you think about deportation
or ICE, all we see
are the Latin faces.
We never see other communities
that are affected
by deportation.
So that brought -- made me aware
of these humans in another way.
I will never go to Harlem and
bypass one of these
African hair-braiding places
without at least
sticking my head in,
saying hi or something,
because these are real people
with real lives.
And this -- this is a really
big piece of our culture.
I remember working
at the Pentagon.
I would show up one day
with my hair short,
and the next day, I come in
with braids like this,
and they'd be like,
"Yesterday..."
and I'd be like,
"I ate my spinach."
[ Laughter ]
But this is a great play.
If you want to know how Black
hair works, come see the play.
-There you go, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I will.
-Yeah, but it's a play
by women, for women.
You know, we rock, women, so...
-You do.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I will say,
Manhattan Theatre Club
just announced
that the show is getting
extended for another week.
Congratulations to you, bud!
-It's that good.
Really good.
-Taraji P. Henson!
"Jaja's African Hair Braiding"
is now playing
at the Samuel J. Friedman
Theater on Broadway!